(audience cheering)
- Oh, thank you, thank you all.
And, oh, thank you, man, for...
God, did it again!
Awesome!
Well, as Denzel says,
we've come a long way
and done a lot of things,
so I'm really, really proud
to receive this statue.
Another standout memory to
add to our shared experiences.
This is awesome.
First, thank you, governors,
for this incredible honor.
Who knew, you know, a little kid
from Chattanooga, Tennessee,
watching movies and
wishing he could be here,
would get the votes of people
who run an organization
like this that says,
"Hey, I deserve something like this"?
Thank you so very much.
(audience clapping)
And I will say when I
got this call last year,
it was totally unexpected,
but I guarantee you this
thing's gonna be cherished.
As long as I dreamt, and imagined,
and practiced this speech,
you know, oughta be a piece of cake.
But (sighs) it's not.
"Together for Days," Stan,
my first film credit in 1972
to here, 50 years later.
It's been a real pleasure
making indelible impressions
on audiences as Gang Member Number Two,
Bum, Hold Up Man,
and the unforgettable, Black Guy.
(audience laughing)
Just to name a few.
But every little taste of
this biz made me want more.
All those Saturdays I spent
at the Liberty and the Grand,
the segregated theaters
of my youth and childhood
in Chattanooga, Tennessee,
imagining that I was Errol
Flynn or Kirk Douglas,
or even James Cagney, even John Wayne.
But going home and
recreating those stories
with my friends or just by myself.
Being awed during the Blaxploitation era,
wishing I was up on that
screen and wondering,
"How the hell do you get
in a movie like that?"
Discovering Peter Sellers, Bond,
the Shaw Brothers, George Lucas.
I knew I loved it, I just didn't
know how to make it happen.
And, fortunately, when it
did, in 1990, I was sober.
Loved and supported by
my wife and daughter.
My reasons for being,
and my biggest critics,
and my biggest fans.
(audience clapping)
I knew very little about
navigating this world,
but I was gifted with
a wonderful publicist
named Lisa Kasteler.
Who had to explain to me what she did,
and then she went out and did it.
Then came Eli Selden.
She came to a location shoot,
contract in hand for a
movie and a proposition
I couldn't refuse to be my manager.
Thank you, E.
She, in turn, led me to
ICM and Carla Hacken,
who paired me with the
legend that is Toni Howard.
(audience clapping)
And Carter Cohn.
And the piece de resistance showed up,
my lawyer, Deborah Klein.
Too amazing to describe
are the engines of what became
and continues to be a
rather decent career,
with the extra added piece
of Karen (indistinct).
(audience clapping)
A gigantic thanks to
each and every one of you
for the scripts, the
deals, the faith in me,
the push to be better,
and making sure I lived
in the comfort zone
of knowing what the
next two jobs would be.
'Cause, you know I love you for that.
John Rigney and Level
Four, a wink and a nod,
and a thanks for that call
I asked you to make to
me when you made it.
The dream has been shared
with my partner in crime,
my critic in residence,
my rock-solid foundation,
and my best friend, LaTanya.
(audience clapping)
We wanted to be Burton and Taylor,
but the Richardson-Jackson-Jackson pairing
has been quite formidable.
You've allowed me to indulge
my work habit to excess,
a lot of times, at the
expense of your own ambition.
This award is a shared accomplishment.
It's always been a two-man show.
A laugh out loud, thanks to Zoe,
for going to work with
me all over the world
and indulging my movie taste
as a viewer and a daughter.
And when I got the opportunity,
I tried to represent this
business the best I knew how.
I got out there to entertain audiences
the way Hollywood entertained me.
Make them forget their
lives for a few hours
and be thrilled, awed, or
excited in the big room
where make believe lives.
Thanks to every person
that's ever bought a ticket
to any movie I was in.
It's truly been an honor and
a pleasure to entertain you.
QT, thanks for the characters.
Little Rob, I know you back there!
Robert Louis Stevenson, the
man who created all those wigs.
Every time I asked him, I said to him,
"Make me somebody," and he did.
Once again, thank you,
governors, for the recognition.
It's an honor.
(audience cheering)